Dogs are not usually relaxed in a lab environment...
...but with a little petting and lots of treats,...
...they can be trained to sit still even in an MRI scanner.
That's how researchers at Hungary's ELTE University...
...were able to get images of their brains at work.
Research fellow Attila Andics says...
...it helped them better understand the dogs' relationship with humans.
We have known for a long time that dogs and humans share similar social environment,...
...but now our results show that dogs and humans also have similar brain mechanisms...
...to process social information.
After training 11 dogs to stay motionless while their brains were scanned,...
...the researchers checked their neurological responses...
...to about 200 emotionally relevant sounds,...
...from whining and crying to playful barking and laughing.
They then compared the responses from human subjects.
They found striking similarities.
Andics says it opens new possibilities for research.
The canine mind is also being studied at Duke University in North Carolina.
Co-Director of the school's Canine Cognition Center, Evan MacLean,...
...says that the Hungarian results are an important step forward.
And what that tells ordinary dog owners, the Hungarian scientists say,...
...is to treat your canine companions as friends, not mere animals,...
...because they evidently understand human feelings.
For writer George Putic, I'm Steve Baragona in Washington.